aliens colonial marines is a game that I
gratefully caught to play before any of
the reviews really came out I played it
on opening day I didn't look up any
videos about it I really knew about was
like things I had read in my electronic
gaming monthly or my Game Informer which
I have over there which I'm too lazy to
get up and get but you know there was a
good article in here about it and there
was all this buzz about it and people
were excited about it you know even
though it was in development for so long
gearbox had a hold of this game but it
was outsourced to timegate as well to do
work on it and according to this guy
that recently came out saying hey you
know what I actually worked for the
people who made this game and let me
just tell you a few things he basically
said that gearbox didn't really have
much control over this game and the
majority of the time they were making
this game they were actually working on
Borderlands 2 and a lot of other people
had control over this game which kind of
explains a lot of the problems behind
this game yes this game sucks this is
going to be my first negative game
review I played this game for the ps3
and right off the bat one of the first
things I noticed was just how bad the
graphics were now I play retro games I
still play NES games all the time I'm a
retro gamer as you can see that doesn't
mean that when I play a ps3 game I don't
expect it to have ps3 level graphics I
would like it to have graphics better
than ps2 because to be honest putting
this game in there you're like wow
that's some pretty good PlayStation 2
graphics or dang this Nintendo GameCube
game looks really good on the ps3
essentially what this game is it's like
an unofficial sequel to aliens
unfortunately some people are treating
this as like a Canon entry into the
series which shouldn't happen trust me
basically you control this marine who
goes to lv-426
and he's investigating the wreckage of
what happened there you see Bishop cut
in half on the floor you get a lot of
fanservice like that the gun has the
same sound effects the aliens make the
same sound effects one of the cool and
best features of this game is you get
that sonar beep or detector that tells
you when the alien or another form is
near you and it beeps and it gets higher
pitched and more fast as something comes
closer to you it actually builds
suspense and pretty much the only
suspenseful tension building element of
the game something kind of annoy me
about this game that is just really a
thing for me that most people may not be
annoyed with it bothers me when I can't
invert the controls I like to invert my
controls because I grew up when
first-person shooters were pretty much
all inverted on the Nintendo 64 it's not
hard for a developer to allow you to
invert your controls this game allows
you to invert your vertical axis but not
your horizontal axis why why in the
world would you want to invert just that
but not left and right it doesn't make
sense to me that's just a little nitpick
that I have that may not affect you if
you prefer your controls to be normal I
like them inverted it's not hard for a
game developer to allow you to do that
one of the worst aspects of this game is
definitely the controls for one you have
to hold down l3 to sprint the left
analog stick you have to click it in if
you want to sprint do you have any idea
how hard that actually is to do in the
middle of shooting a whole bunch of
aliens it's not even good for your
controller you like press it in all hard
then you click upwards really fast and
then finally you can sprint it feels
like you're about to rip that left
analog stick right out of the controller
it's so uncomfortable they should just
head you hold down l2 to sprint or
something like that if there's ammo on
the ground or health or something to
pick it up you have to press square
simple enough right
wrong you actually have to look down at
the ground at the ammo or whatever it is
you have to have it on screen while
looking at it and then you can press
square and pick it up
you can't just press square near you
actually have to turn your character and
center it directly in the screen to pick
up whatever it is you're trying to pick
up isn't that horrible didn't someone
come out and go you know what that's
probably not a good idea to have it like
that your gun has seemingly endless ammo
like you never actually feel any tension
like oh I might run out of ammo it's
like you just have these endless rounds
of ammunition and the shotgun the
shotgun is so simple to kill the
Xenomorphs it's almost always one-shot
kill it's really sad
speaking of the xenomorph no tension
there whatsoever they are a mindless
army drone of nothingness the only scary
thing about this game is the fact that
they can jump up in front of you with
literally no sound effects of whatsoever
because they just don't have any sound
effects inserted for them walking on the
ground it's just like they're these
hovering things and all of a sudden
they're there and that's the only scary
element of this game is that the control
the sound effects and the gameplay
elements are so poorly done that you
could just die as you're walking and
because it's behind you all of a sudden
Oh didn't hear that thing coming you can
actually turn and see it literally
crawling up a wall or coming up towards
you and there is literally no sound
effects for its reactions with the
environment at all another huge issue of
this game is your reactions with your
partner if you're playing single-player
like I did you have a guy who's running
with you this guy is an idiot he says
the dumbest things in the world we walk
into a room where there's a few dead
bodies and they have these things like
they exploded out of their chests
there's all this alien blood everywhere
and what does he say hmm something's not
right you think buddy I can't even tell
you how many times he said watch out
look up at the ceiling and I would look
up and there'd be nothing there and I
would die because the alien was actually
already right in front of me the moments
in this game in which dialogue are
supposed to happen to get you to follow
through with an element of gameplay are
completely mixed up there are times when
he goes to cut a door oh my god this was
one of the funniest things in the whole
game okay you have a door cutter but
yeah you never actually get to control
it or use it in any way you basically
just walk up to a door and press a
button and you watch your guy go like
this wouldn't be cool if you could
actually cut open a door yourself anyway
the guy your partner is trying to cut
open this door now the door is right
here in front of him and I'm looking at
him and he's literally going like this
Shh
Shh and the door that it's right here
just go with birch and falls down I was
like yeah you got it there buddy your
aim is fantastic this game malfunctions
and glitches so many times it is
absolutely laughable it really is if
you're killed in this game which by the
way is really easy because as I said you
never hear an alien approaching you
would just oh there it is and then
you're suddenly stuck in this extremely
close up battle in which these little
black tails and arms are suddenly just
kind of flashing around you and maybe
every once in a while if you back up
you'll actually see one of them and to
be able to kill it with your incredibly
amazing basically gold pp7 from
Goldeneye shotgun which is in one shot
kill them there you did it let's just
say one of these things does kill you
you are greeted with the weirdest grey
frozen image death screen and you're
like what does this even mean like the
game just freezes for like 10 seconds
with this grey image and then aliens
just like standing there over you like
okay what what the where to go where
what oh there he is okay I swear this
isn't because I suck
what the what the hell is this there was
one last bit of this game that I had
hope for that was the multiplayer
because you can actually play as a
xenomorph and that sounds interesting
that sounds fun alright so I went online
I played some multiplayer for a while as
the xenomorph first off you are
automatically nerfed in so many ways
because all of the people you are
fighting which are the Marines have
projectile weapons they can shoot at you
with grenades and shotguns and machine
guns you cannot do anything unless you
are directly in front of them and you
can swipe at them which means that all
of these guys that are huddled into an
army all they got to do is all shoot at
you as you approach them it's not fun to
play as a Cena morph because you're
completely nerfed in every way your
powers are weaker than them in every
possible way the only way you have any
chance of beating one of these guys is
if somehow one of them actually strays
from the pack which never happened by
the way and somehow you can stealth them
without them noticing that there's this
giant alien just coming right up to him
but of course that actually might happen
since you don't have any sound effects
as you move so it's not fun to play as a
xenomorph the multiplayer sucks there's
so many glitches in this game where
random freeze-frame images from other
items that you maybe could be holding
but aren't holding actually just insert
into the game for like a split second
it's absurd actually how unfinished this
game is and according to this guy who
came out on reddit saying that I was a
developer for this game and this is what
happened apparently the game was like
outsourced by gearbox to timegate
Studios because they were putting so
much effort into Borderlands 2 the game
kept being revamped over the course of
the years and completely changed so like
the great demos that people played last
year there's like not even a little part
of it still in this game I can
understand where that may have happened
you know it would have been nice to
finally have a good aliens game because
there aren't too many of them out there
this is definitely not the one aliens
colonial Marines you my friend get a
four out of ten one of the only things
this game has going forward as it
actually does have the voice of corporal
Hicks which is pretty cool it has a few
nostalgic elements for fans by reusing
some of the same sound effects and
weaponry that you actually did see in
the original aliens movie but with an
extremely short campaign terrible
control gameplay elements and a really
awful and unfun multiplayer this game
just sucks gratefully though I rented
this thing didn't have to pay 64 and I
can't imagine how any of you who
did feel alright guys so my next new
game review is going to be for male Gear
Rising that comes out tomorrow I'll try
to beat it as soon as I can so I can
tell you guys what I think about it I'm
a huge metal gear fan as always guys
thanks for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes